to drive the plane to 8 000 feet
it is possible yes it should come down
like a rock like really fast we are
trained to do that in case of severe
emergency hi my name is Captain Zoya
Agarwal I am a commander on the Boeing
triple seven with Air India and I have
been doing this for the last 18 years
today we're going to be looking at Pilot
emergencies and movies and judge how
real they are
we're in an uncontrolled dive descending
out a 21
000 feed got a jam stabilizer or
something they are an uncontrollable die
but they also have a problem with the
stabilizer which basically keeps the
airplane stable in the pitch control
pitch means like vertically to go up and
down Evan Listen to me when I say I want
you to retract the flaps retract the
gear trim us nose down whatever they
trim down this is not how it's supposed
to be as a pilot you are ingrained with
this thought from the very beginning
whenever something goes wrong pick up
the quick reference handbook which has a
list of all the potential failures
including this second command my
co-pilot to pull a checklist I would
follow that realistically he's trying to
turn down he's trying to get the flaps
out he's trying to get the gear out I
don't know what he's trying to do for me
it's a very huge walk outside the box
which I would not step out of when I
tell you I want you to push these
forward full power Full Throttle can you
do that you will never call a flight
attendant into the flight deck to help
you to fly when both of you are alive
you have a two-man flight tag one is a
captain and one is a co-pilot and that's
all that you need so it's absolutely
unrealistic here we go I've got control
this is based on a real life incident
the Alaska Air flight 261 in January
2000. this is a very extreme maneuver I
respect in real life whatever Captain
may have done the only planes that fly
inverted are acrobats and probably
military it's an mg80 and this is not
approved and test flown for that they're
supposed to be secured our overhead
lockers the manufacturers design it in
the best of the way if maybe sometimes
passenger may leave it open maybe that's
why
commendable
we can say that now because the flight
went on for two more minutes my
assessment of the situation would be
follow the checklist do your best and
that's it zero because inward flight and
everything that does not make any sense
to me
this flight was Sichuan air from
chunking to lhasa they had a wind chill
crack and the compiler got sucked out
because of the differential pressure
he's just trying to come down really
fast so he could reduce that facial
pressure and the less the differential
pressure he could easily like pull him
back inside the flight deck that was
realistic
foreign
called gpws which does not allow us to
apply so close to the terrain like
mountainous region would have been going
all over the place in real life because
it warns you way ahead of any possible
coalition
did you see the skulk 7700 that is the
emergency score code you enter 7700 on
the transponder they will move mountains
for you the air traffic controller
because they know that you're dealing
with an emergency situation and try and
help you out as much as they can number
two you saw a cabin crew member came
inside the flight deck the cockpit to
help him out that's the kind of scenario
that will warrant that not when two
pilots are awake and absolutely fine and
fed
every storm is different the storm like
visually is something that you will see
on your weather radar you would also see
what kind of storm it is it's a
convective activity what is happening
within the storm and you know after
years of experience we know the kind of
build-up that is and how far oh this was
realistic except for like that thinking
of the mountain so I think I'll subtract
like two marks eight
let's see the hell was that this is
absolutely not realistic if you were to
have damaged wheels for whatever reason
there could be adverse effects if you
remember the Concord crash where this
airplane was taking off from Paris to
New York and the debris from the wheel
it got inside the fuel tank and it
ruptured it and it kind of just blew up
the whole Concorde unfortunately so even
a small piece of debris can have a huge
impact the only thing which made it more
palatable for me is the seat belts
people would at least see that thank God
for that
take over
if there was some emergency I would
always be in the flight deck to solve it
first and take it from there
you cannot hit an object with an
airplane airplanes are very
aerodynamically clean the way they're
supposed to fly do you remember Sully
like something a small bird how it can
just take away the engines
this is the impact when you're adding
speed and a foreign material or foreign
body minus ten sorry but what do I do
please show me something realistic
mayday mayday mayday mayday we have lost
Mayday is definitely not just in the
movies there are many ways of doing
different things to let the air traffic
controller know that you're suffering in
an emerging situation however when you
say made it made it made it it
definitely just straight away tracks
attention and everybody just goes quiet
because they know that you require that
emergent attention
the only job when there is actually a
need to be dropped like in case of a
loss of cabin pressure but this does not
happen there is no loss of cabin
pressure over here
well of course I have um heard of having
a rat or something if one passenger
spots one rat that entire airplane is
sealed up fumed for a very long time
it's not about
an animal it's about the damage because
if you think about a rat it can chew up
wires which can potentially control the
flight controls oh my God mine is too I
like the fact that you're wearing their
uniform and that's it
how much fuel you have sir
only about 920 kgs
that means hardly one or two attempts I
love Bollywood they were very very low
on fuel that situation should never come
in aviation because you're dealing with
human lives you're in air we always have
enough contingency plans in place to
have enough fuel with us at any given
point in time and if we don't we
initiate our plan B which is a diversion
much before even if you have low fuel
you don't linger around at a place which
has bad weather you go to some other
choice to start with
clear for landing Runway one six no
you're under 34.
34 is
The Office Dale wind this is a very
unrealistic scenario except for the fact
that the air traffic controllers were
surprised that he was coming into the
landing with high Tailwinds what he was
trying to say was that typically people
Landing when you go in you should
ideally have bins coming from the head
and if you have Tailwinds which is
coming from behind you you tend to touch
down
a little bit more into the Run bait if
you're Landing in terrible storm well we
have limitations we abide by that the
air traffic control was shocked because
obviously the winds were probably much
much more than his limitations
you know this is so weird because the
co-pilot
I mean I love the fact they've shown a
woman but you know the co-pilot has to
be assertive my first officers I've
always told them you're the second in
command this airplane after me is like
you're in charge always act like one
it's a part of our
crew briefings that if there is anything
that you're not comfortable with me
doing you call that out
don't get me started would you even
cross the road with the eyes closed I
mean you wouldn't even walk out this
door with your eyes closed you're
dealing with human lives minus hundred
because blind Landing oh my God no I
need you to drop the plane to 8 000 feet
get to the lowest pressure differential
you can
[Applause]
this is definitely more realistic
basically what he's trying to say is in
case of a rapid decompression when we
have like a decompression within the
airplane you're inside of the cabin
pressure is really high and outside is
really low so your differential pressure
or Delta p as we call it is higher which
is really detrimental which is why the
mass coming down otherwise you cannot
breathe the pilot put the airplane in
that kind of an attitude to kind of
sabotage the efforts of the gunman and
destabilize him and doing whatever
potential damage he was doing so that
was a great move
[Applause]
it is possible yes to come down like a
rock like really fast we are trained to
do that in case of severe emergency in
case of Rapid decompression that does
require you to descend really really
fast because every single nanosecond
that you're spending time wasting or not
coming down down you can potentially
have a lot of damage behind the cabin
people passing out because of lack of
oxygen
effect of an explosion is far more like
it's a depressurization and potentially
you have a far bigger impact in terms of
the damage we do have protocol the
following case of explosives I do not
know if I can openly discuss that out
an airplane can have a partial damage to
it and it can still very much land back
so long as your controls are not
affected there is no major damage to the
essential surfaces which are required
for the flight control of the airplane
they are fully functioning they're
designed to be like that let's give them
too I'm feeling good generous
tell him to take off
oh my God I love that part totally a
killer
you would never just take off on a whim
you know hey I feel like taking off and
somebody's calling me take off it
doesn't work like that the factors of
takeoff speed depends on many things
even if like one degree of temperature
change is liked when change or pressure
change we recalculate our takeoff
performance for example You're Expecting
300 passengers and 100 of them don't
show up that changes the takeoff
performance we have this figured out way
in advance and we ensure even if like
there is a minute change to it
we recalculate everything but rest
assured it's never a woman calling us on
the phone take off take off
you would never have a car even close to
a Runway it's all very sterile
environment in real life airports what
you're essentially doing is there's drag
me at it which is pulling it down along
with the weight and when you're taking
off a huge jet like answered off you
don't have any room for any drag like
nothing at all
unfortunately when something like this
happens in real life upon impact with
the fuel and everything these things do
tend to happen but this is ridiculous
under my command such a scenario would
not even happen because I will never
ever come on the runway if I do not have
my take off performance calculated and
adjusted to the T and not only me every
single pilot to keep safety Paramount
minus 20.
foreign
I'm missing Captain sullenberger he did
such a great job and it's also making it
more dramatic version of it it's come to
a whole just right there before the
bridge it's brilliant because obviously
he has no control over the water there
are so many other factors at play as
well which eventually will decide the
way it's going to turn out the current
of the water the direction in which it's
flowing based on the winds it can play a
role like we've had Hull losses where
the airplane has broken up on impact
when they've had to ditch over water
there's a pilot it's not in your hands
you still do what you can do for your
best that's just luck they came together
for Captain sullenberger so I'm guessing
for him also it can come together it's a
five only because of Captain
sullenberger this is dedicated to him my
favorite public emergency in a movie is
Sully oh he did the whole Landing over
the hot son thanks for watching and if
you've enjoyed this why not click here